c'est un sujet difficile dont plusieurs
préféraient ne pas entendre parler les
maladies liées à l'exposition aux
pesticides cancer maladie neurologiques
chez les agriculteurs et leurs familles
la science indépendante et de plus en
plus claire en France on a reconnu un
lien entre l'utilisation des pesticides
et plusieurs pathologies au Québec cela
la maladie de Parkinson fait l'objet
d'une telle reconnaissance mais des deux
côtés de l'Atlantique obtenir une
indemnisation relève encore du parcours
du combattant
il nourrissent la planète et ils
laissent leur santé
moi je considère que les pesticides ont
écrabouillé ma vie quoi
insecticide fongicide herbicide produit
anti-parasitaire la science parle
implacable
l'héritage des pesticides clairement
c'est tout un tas de pathologies qui
sont des pathologies du vieillissement
et c'est des maladies graves et souvent
irréversibles il lutte pour faire
reconnaître leur maladie et obtenir
compensation
pour défendre nos droits des personnes
malades et ils ne sont pas seuls les
avancées obtenues chez les uns
pourraient faire grandir les autres mais
c'est un réel parcours du combattant
parce qu'on est en train de vivre un
véritable scandale sanitaire pour la
santé des personnes exposées aux
pesticides
nous voit tout en Bretagne un village
historique
tout autour des arbres fruitiers
vestigent des vergers d'autrefois et des
champs de maïs et de blé noir un coin de
paradis pour un agriculteur et sa
famille
c'est dans cette maison bretonne de la
fin du 15e siècle que Christian Jouault
s'installe en 1994 il est loin de se
douter que la maladie de sa femme
Armelle lui fera vivre quelques années
plus tard un véritable enfer on venait
de fêter nos 25 ans de mariage c'était
donc en 2002 elle était pas bien elle
était fatiguée elle avait des soucis de
santé
le diagnostic tombe Armel
souffre
qu'il n'y a son médecin soupçonne qu'il
y a un lien entre son cancer et
l'exposition aux pesticides
filles de paysans est là longtemps été
en contact avec les produits chimiques
[Musique]
et donc Armel elle suivait le pulvé
pendant de sa plus tendre enfance
jusqu'à ce qu'on se marie avec une lance
c'est derrière tous les ans d'après ce
qu'elle avait raconté au médecin qui a
soigné sur l'info elle prenait une
dizaine de douches de pesticides pendant
une dizaine d'années donc à un moment
elle a payé le prix de ses
elle avait pourtant convaincu son mari
d'abandonner l'agriculture
conventionnelle et de passer au bio
pour Armel ce sera trop tard elle rend
l'âme en 2006
neuvant plus tard le mauvais sort s'abat
cette fois sur Christian Jouault
puis un beau jour une terrible envie de
pisser et puis je vais aux toilettes et
c'était que du sang et donc on m'envoie
immédiatement au centre anti-cancéreux
et là on détecte un cancer on fait 16
biopsies les biopsies sont toutes
cancéreuses
souffrent d'une forme agressive de
cancer de la prostate là encore les
médecins font le lien avec les
pesticides auxquelles il a été exposé
pendant plus de 30 ans
j'avais 15-6 ans et puis mon père avait
acheté un tracteur quelques temps avant
on a acheté un pulvé moi j'étais sur le
tracteur torse nu enfin sans aucune
protection quand on mettait des produits
dans le tonneau à pulvérisé sans aucune
protection et nous arrivait même des
fois quand ça se mélangait pas bien d'y
mettre la main enfin c'était c'était
abominable mais à l'époque d'abord
j'étais jeune j'avais pas bien
conscience de ça et puis j'imaginais que
ces produits là ils étaient dangereux
quand on les buvait quand on n'est pas
quand on les respirait
à la retraite Serge Giard est lui aussi
en contact avec les pesticides pendant
une trentaine d'années avant de prendre
le virage bio
spécialement par le fonction que
j'exerçais sur ma ferme c'est
l'insecticide qu'on appliqué sur les
animaux et à l'intérieur de la grange
c'est le contact que j'ai eu le plus
le plus régulier avec les pesticides
[Musique]
à l'automne 2014 son corps commence à
lui envoyer des signaux inquiétants j'ai
été réveillé par des spas au bras gauche
et à la jambe gauche
j'ai consulté mon médecin de famille
elle m'a confirmé c'était du Parkinson
garde sa maladie secrète pendant près de
5 ans
que quand on connaît les maladies c'est
comme une période de
Condy tout parce que en quoi pas que
c'est possible
au Québec on débat de plus en plus de la
question controversée des pesticides en
2019 une commission parlementaire se
penche sur leurs impacts sur la santé et
l'environnement Serge Giard brise enfin
le silence
spécialiste des maladies
professionnelles
qui a confirmé que
mes années précédentes avaient YouTube
biologique sont responsables de ma
maladie
Québec cette organisation défendra les
personnes malades en raison d'une
exposition aux pesticides
à faire mais si je pouvais aider ou
collaborer à empêcher des personnes à
attraper cette maladie-là je leur ai pas
fait pour rien
non moi je suis plutôt
de l'école de dire que on y va on dit
vrai chaude concentré
sa jeune association de défense des
agriculteurs malades en compagnie
d'Amandine François et de Pascal priori
l'organisme dispose de bien maigres
moyens mais les besoins eux sont énormes
qu'est-ce qu'on dit aux personnes qui
nous contactent chaque jour et qui nous
demandent mais pourquoi pourquoi je
devrais aller au tribunal pourquoi je
devrais me battre alors que je suis
malade pourquoi on m'aide pas plus
on peut pas accompagner ces personnes si
on n'a pas les moyens de le faire s'il y
a pas une volonté politique de le faire
s'il y a pas une volonté administrative
une mobilisation des personnes qui sont
compétentes et capables de le faire et
nous aujourd'hui on a besoin de moyens
pour faire ce travail
Christian Jouault lui compte sur l'appui
du président du collectif de l'Ouest
Michel Besnard
du monde
salut Michel
on est une association que de bénévoles
et qui refuse toute subvention pour être
indépendant de tout pouvoir
médical final mais tu n'étais pas
convoqué 9 mois après tu étais pas
convoqué le regroupant soutient les
victimes des pesticides en Bretagne
comme Christian et Armel
[Musique]
à la retraite
avec l'aide du collectif Christian
Jouault se battent en justice notre
manière de nous faire connaître de faire
connaître que les pesticides rendent
malades des gens qui font mourir et donc
notre action est basée sur la solidarité
et quand on va au tribunal on y vient à
30 bah ça donne la force aux gens
d'aller jusqu'au bout de la démarche qui
leur paraît souvent trop longues
Christian joue obtient à l'automne 2020
la reconnaissance de sa maladie
professionnelle et deux ans plus tard il
reçoit finalement une indemnisation tous
les jours je rencontre des gens dans le
collectif qui sont malades à cause de
ces de ces saloperies et je me dis mais
c'est pas possible qu'on puisse
continuer
pendant ce temps au Québec le vent
tourne pour Serge Giard
en mars 2021 le gouvernement reconnaît
finalement qu'il y a un lien entre la
maladie de Parkinson et l'usage de
certains pesticides
le Parkinson devient une maladie
professionnelle reconnue dans la
province chez les agriculteurs et
travailleurs exposés aux pesticides
pour obtenir cette reconnaissance et
être indemnisée un agriculteur doit
répondre à trois critères avoir été
exposé aux pesticides pendant 10 ans ou
plus être diagnostiqué dans les sept ans
suivant la fin de l'exposition au
pesticides
et avoir cotisé à la Commission des
normes de l'équité de la santé et de la
sécurité du travail la CNE SST
ironie du sort Serge Giard ne répond pas
à deux des trois critères il n'a donc
pas droit à une indemnisation on a gagné
que effectivement c'est pas gagné on a
gagné mais c'est pas gagné
[Musique]
la reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle c'est comme beaucoup de
gens nous disent moi je fais pas ça pour
l'argent mais je voudrais pas que ce
soit pour d'autres et donc c'est comme
une reconnaissance
du excusez-moi toujours quand je parle
de ça mais
c'est une reconnaissance de la société
pour le mal que la terre des gens il
veut vivre comme ça
et donc ça c'est vachement important
les pommiers s'alignent à perte de vue
près de 60% de la surface totale des
pommeraies de la province se trouvent
ici en montée régie des vergers
gourmands en pesticides de synthèse
la Grenoble chercheur Gérald Chouinard
travaille dans les vergers depuis 35 ans
il développe des alternatives aux
pesticides pour l'institut de recherche
et de développement en
agro-environnement l'IRDA j'ai été
exposé au moins une trentaine de
matières accès on voyait ça comme des
produits sélectifs sécuritaires à ce
moment-là j’étais plutôt conscient de ma
grande certitude basée sur rien que je
pouvais pas être atteindre quoi que ce
soit
sa certitude est ébranlée en 2019
lorsqu'il apprend qu'il est atteint de
la maladie de Parkinson
il est un employé de l'État Gérald
Chouinard transmet une réclamation à la
cne-st pour que sa maladie
professionnelle soit reconnue il essuie
un refus avec le soutien du groupe
victime des pesticides du Québec il
conteste la décision devant le tribunal
administratif
ce tribunal a reconnu quelques mois plus
tôt qu'un lymphome nonochkinien
diagnostiqué chez un ouvrier agricole
mexicain est une maladie professionnelle
Armando lazo Batista pulvérisait des
pesticides contenant du glyphosate et du
malade dans des vergers et une bleue et
tiède de monter régie
en 2022 le juge donne raison à Gérald
Chouinard la preuve démontre sans
équivoque une exposition professionnelle
à différents pesticides avec un risque
significatif de développer la maladie de
Parkinson
était reconnu deux ans plus tard donc ça
peut être facile mais on a réussi
Gérald Chouinard
lui promet et le seul travailleur
québécois avoir sa condition reconnue
comme maladie professionnelle et donc à
pouvoir toucher des indemnisations et
aucun producteur agricole atteint de la
maladie de Parkinson n'a encore obtenu
cette reconnaissance au Québec
cette reconnaissance et malheureusement
une façade pour la majorité de la
population qui a été exposée au
pesticides une majorité d'agriculteurs
n'a jamais cotisé à la cnsst parce
qu'ils ne sont pas obligés de le faire
donc 9 ans tant de personnes qui ne sont
pas éligibles c'est comme si on dit ben
regardez la maladie de Parkinson et
admissible allez-y mais en fait vous
avez pas le droit ça a aucun sens
en Normandie on suit de près la lutte de
victimes des pesticides du Québec
l'agriculteur Antoine Lambert est le
président de fito victimes la plus
importante association d'aide aux
professionnels des victimes des
pesticides de France fondés en 2011
mais si on se rend Aubine 11 ans en
arrière ce qui est pas si loin que ça la
problématique santé en lien avec les
pesticides on en parlait quasiment pas
c'est peu connu encore
ça va changer quand le fondateur de
Phyto victimes l'agriculteur
Paul-François intoxiquée par un
herbicide entreprend un long combat
judiciaire contre la multinationale
Monsanto
depuis Phyto victimes s'est battu pour
faire reconnaître les droits de près de
600 personnes et les a accompagnés dans
les longues et difficiles des marchés
administratives et juridiques bon on n'a
pas travaillé tout seul loin de là
derrière tout ça et aussi des
scientifiques qui font des travaux
régulièrement qui publient
des chercheurs comme Pierre Le Bailly
qui coordonne la grande enquête
épidémiologique indépendante agricole
lancé en 2005
Agrican suit l'état de santé de 180 000
personnes affiliées à la Mutualité
sociale agricole un régime de protection
sociale obligatoire c'est la plus grande
cohérente mondiale d'agriculteurs jamais
étudié
sur le risque pour la santé des
agriculteurs en terme de cancer
agricole nous apprend que les
agriculteurs présentent moins de cancers
que dans la population générale
cependant il développe beaucoup plus
certains types de cancers que le reste
de la société et là on a vu des excès de
conserve la vessie chez les producteurs
de légumes et les producteurs les gens
qui travaillent dans les sœurs par
exemple on a vu pour le cancer de la
prostate un excès de cancer la prostate
chez les éleveurs de bovins qui mettent
des antiparasitaires sur leurs bovins
on a vu aussi un lien avec
l'arboriculture fruitière et pas
simplement les traitements mais aussi la
récolte
on a travaillé aussi sur la maladie de
Parkinson et là on a vu un lien avec
tous les secteurs de production
l'étude agricole confirme donc des
pathologies comme les lymphomes cancer
de la prostate cancer de la peau et
maladie de Parkinson sont plus fréquents
chez les agriculteurs
ce bagage de nouvelles connaissances et
précieux et donne des munitions à ceux
qui luttent pour les victimes des
pesticides
c'est difficile de nier qui se passe
quelque chose quand vous documentez
régulièrement que vous voyez des effets
si bien qu'en France
pathologiques de Parkinson le lymphome
nanochkinien qui englobe des maladies du
sang comme le miélon multiple et la
leucémie lymphoïde chronique d'autres
maladies du sang tels que certaines
leucémies aigus et enfin le cancer de la
prostate
en France la reconnaissance de ces
maladies professionnelles donne droit à
des rentes elles sont versées par le
régime de protection de la mutualité
sociale agricole et l'ensemble de la
population agricole doit obligatoirement
y cotisée
un fond spécial offre un complément
d'indemnisation aux agriculteurs il
indemnise aussi certains agriculteurs
retraités et les enfants malades dues à
une exposition prénatale aux pesticides
dans la ville lumière l'université
parité regroupe certains des plus grands
chercheurs dans le domaine de la
toxicité des pesticides
Xavier coumoul dirige une équipe de
l'Institut national de la santé et de la
recherche médicale l'Inserm qui a publié
une étude choc en 2021 c'est une
expertise qui a fait toute la revue de
la littérature sur pesticides et santé
et elle vient en complément d'une
précédente expertise qui avait eu lieu
en 2013 et qui déjà montré un certain
nombre de liens entre pesticides
exposition pesticides et certaines
pathologies leur conclusion son
troublantes en milieu professionnel
l'expertise confirme la présomption
forte d'un lien entre l'exposition aux
pesticides et six pathologies à celle
déjà inscrite au tableau des maladies
professionnelles en France s'ajoutent
les troubles cognitifs et des maladies
respiratoires
on montrait notamment qu'il y avait plus
de bronchite chronique chez ces
personnes et aussi plus une plus de
potes d'une pathologie bien particulière
qui est une pathologie obstructive des
bronches
et l'étude établit une présomption de
liens moyen avec la maladie d'Alzheimer
les troubles anxieux-dépressifs des
cancers de la vessie du rein des cancers
des tissus mous et osseux et des
pathologies de la glande thyroïde
alors les agriculteurs sont
particulièrement à risque tout
simplement parce qu'ils sont la
population la plus exposée quand ils
font les pulvérisations donc ce sont des
gens qui sont exposés à pas seulement un
seul type de pesticides mais plusieurs
types de pesticides plusieurs fois dans
l'année et parfois on mélange donc
parfois en plus il y a des effets
cocktails et ses effets cocktails eux
ils sont pas du tout appréhendés
aux audiences de la commission sur les
impacts des pesticides la chercheuse
Maryse Bouchard déplore le manque de
connaissances sur les risques des
pesticides pour la santé humaine vous
seriez surpris de savoir à quel point il
y a peu d'études sur les pesticides puis
au Québec franchement on en a pas
[Musique]
tout simplement pas d'appétit de la part
du gouvernement pour financer ce genre
de travaux là on sent pas vraiment
vouloir savoir quels sont les effets sur
la santé quand on étudie pas quelque
chose ben on le sait pas puis c'est sûr
et certain que dès qu'on parle des
pesticides il y a des gros gros intérêts
financiers qui sont derrière ça c'est
une immense industrielle industrie des
pesticides et on voit qu'ils ont des
forts
le président de Phyto victimes lui
souhaite protéger la relève comme sa
fille Héloïse armée des conclusions des
scientifiques il prépare les prochaines
batailles en reconnaissance de maladies
professionnelles il y a des
problématiques pulmonaires et puis
toutes les maladies neurodégénératives
même si on a déjà Parkinson aujourd'hui
on se pose quand même beaucoup de
questions sur d'autres d'autres maladies
et une autre bataille se dessine en
France la santé des voisins des
agriculteurs est une source grandissante
de préoccupation depuis une dizaine
d'années maintenant les chercheurs
documents l'exposition des riverains aux
pesticides
à l'ombre du château de Bourg dérangé de
vignes aux raisins parfaitement murs la
période des vendanges approche
ce vignoble bordelais fait partie d'une
des régions viticoles les plus
prestigieuses au monde on y produit des
vins réputés et des crus d'exception
ce décor de rêve est le théâtre d'un
combat que mène Valérie Murat contre
l'industrie du vin
son père vigneront succombe à un cancer
broncho pulmonaire en 2012 il est exposé
pendant des décennies à l'arsenic de
sodium un puissant fongicide qui traite
les vignes contre un champignon le
caractère professionnel de sa maladie
est reconnue un an avant sa mort
quand il a été diagnostiqué ça a été un
coup de massue pour lui et pour notre
famille parce que mon père pendant toute
sa carrière pendant plus de 40 ans avait
respecté toutes les précautions d'usage
et toutes les règles qui existaient pour
ne pas tomber malade
son père souhaitait poursuivre
l'industrie chimique et l'État français
mais n'a jamais eu le temps de le faire
en France les pandage de l'arsenic de
sodium dans les vignes n'a été interdit
qu'en 2001 malgré le fait qu'il était
classé dangereux depuis 1955
donc on homologue des produits dont on
est parfaitement la dangerosité mais on
dit que si on respecte les conditions
les précautions d'usage il n'y a pas de
danger et bien ça c'est une foutaise
c'est une foutaise et c'est ce qui a
fait que mon père a été empoisonné et
qu'il en est mort
Valérie Murat a repris le flambeau avec
l'association qu'elle a fondé alerte au
toxique elle milite pour l'abolition
complète des pesticides en viticulture
il y a quelques années je disais encore
que il fallait passer par des étapes en
supprimant en priorité les plus
dangereux mais non on est arrivé à un
tel niveau d'exposition et
d'empoisonnement il faut aller très vite
en France la viticulture
occupe 4% de la surface agricole
utile et elle utilise beaucoup de
pesticides 20% de tous les pesticides
utilisés en agriculture au pays
séjour de vendanges chez Laurent Perrot
un rituel auquel se prête sa famille
depuis cette générations
il fait partie des viticulteurs français
qui produisent maintenant un vin moins
gourmand en pesticides il est de plus en
plus conscient des dangers de ces
produits chimiques pour la santé on doit
s'inquiéter parce que les produits qu'on
nous propose on les connaît pas on les
connaît pas bien en tout cas et on
apprend 10 ans après avoir utilisé un
produit par exemple que il est devenu
cancérigène ah oui mais pourquoi on le
sait pas avant c'est vrai qu'on a le
droit de s'inquiéter il cultive
c'est sur les coteaux de la région et à
proximité du village sur ces 47 hectares
il a réduit du tiers les applications de
pesticides
est-ce que vous voisins vous en parle
est-ce qu'ils ont constaté des
changements on a aucun problème avec nos
voisins je pense que on est nous
attentifs au respect de l'environnement
et je pense que c'est bien perçu
vis-à-vis de arrivera on n'a pas de
souci
pourtant médecin et scientifique
français eux s'interrogent sur la santé
des riverains
surtout suite à la faire Preignac dans
ce village de la région viticole de
Sauternes les cas de cancer chez les
enfants se multiplient la communauté
suspecte l'épandage de pesticides près
de l'école et sonne l'alarme en 2012
une enquête de l'agence régionale de
santé conclut qu'il y a à Preignac six
fois plus de cancer pédiatrique que la
normale
un excès quel juge cependant modéré
pouvant être lié à une exposition aux
pesticides
des conclusions que contestent
l'association alerte des médecins sur
les pesticides oui il y a trop peu
d'enfants pour tirer valablement des
conséquences ça on est d'accord mais
vous possédez des données nationales des
cancers de l'enfant donc on a la
localisation très précise de tous les
cas de leucémie dans toutes les régions
viticoles de France faisant une étude
sur ces régions viticoles et vérifions
si les cas ont un risque supplémentaire
lié à leur exposition
l'étude est réalisée et elle confirme
les craintes de l'association
à chaque augmentation de densité de
culture en ville de 10% dans un rayon
d'un kilomètre autour du domicile de
l'enfant on trouve une augmentation de
risque de leucémie de 5 à 10% elle aussi
est-ce que par exemple on doit continuer
la culture de vigne
au risque de créer des leucémies
donc cette question est-ce qu'elle est
en tandem ou pas moi je la pose
une autre étude nationale a grande
échelle est en cours dans six régions
viticoles de France l'étude pestirive
elle a pour but d’identifier et de
comparer l'exposition aux pesticides des
gens résidents près des vignes et de
ceux vivant loin de toute culture
3350 personnes y participent et les
résultats seront dévoilés en 2024
la viticulture est à la France ce que la
polyculture est au Québec depuis des
décennies la production de pommes
nécessite une grande quantité de
pesticides de synthèse
les maisons et les établissements
publics sont souvent enclavés dans les
vergers et pourtant on sait peu de
choses sur la santé des populations
riveraines une rare études a été
réalisée au Québec à la fin des années
90 par la Direction de la santé publique
76 personnes y ont participé
c'est une étude modeste quelques
dizaines d'enfants et on a mesuré leur
exposition dans l'urine c'est la façon
la plus pratique pour pour évaluer ça et
on a regardé si il y avait plus de
résidus de pesticides dans l'urine après
qu'il y ait eu des épandages de
pesticides ou chez les enfants qui
vivaient plus proches de verger versus
ce qui vivait plus loin et on a vu sans
grandes surprises que effectivement les
enfants qui étaient plus proches de
verger avec plus de pesticides
ces données inquiète la spécialiste en
santé environnementale ses propres
travaux de recherche démontrent que
l'exposition au pesticides lors de la
grossesse pose des risques pour les
enfants
ce qu'on voit c'est que donc
l'exposition prénatale est associée à
des effets qu'on peut observer quand on
fait quand on suit le développement des
enfants par exemple sur la capacité
d'attention leur capacité de langage
hier capacité intellectuelle puis ça
peut réduire aussi des problèmes de
comportement
manga d'attention des choses comme ça
je sais que les agriculteurs les
familles d'agriculteurs sont inquiets se
demandent quels sont les impacts sur eux
en famille leur communauté aussi quelles
sont les effets sur tous ces gens-là qui
sont directement impliqués c'est peu ou
pas connu à ce moment-ci
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est la journée dépendage
chez le maraîcher Jean-Marie Zumstein de
sherington en Montérégie
il s'apprête à pulvériser un herbicide
pour lutter contre les graminées dans
ces champs de coriandre
ces deux fois par semaine je dirais à
peu près pendant deux trois heures de
temps et c'est plusieurs produits qu'il
faut manipuler c'est des fausses des
insecticides des herbicides
l'herbicide que Jean-Marie va utiliser
n'est pas sans risque
sur l'étiquette on peut lire la matière
active de ce produit peut causer des
malformations congénitales et des effets
néfastes sur les fœtus des rats les
femmes capables de procréer doivent
faire preuve d'une extrême prudence en
l'utilisant
conscient de la toxicité de l'herbicide
Jean-Marie porte un équipement de
protection il enfile un tablier en
caoutchouc un masque avec filtre et des
gants en néoprène j'ai pas toujours 1000
masques mais j'ai toujours mis les gants
j'essaye d'évoluer aussi parce que je
pense on est de plus en plus
conscientiser aussi
les vrais affaires parce qu'on est
toujours autour c'est inconfortable de
le mettre si on sauve du temps si on le
met pas on y pense pas il y a plein de
raisons pour pas le mettre là
lorsqu'il est vêtu de son équipement le
producteur à la conviction d'être
adéquatement protégé
les produits de protection sont de bonne
qualité l'important c'est de bien les
porter puis bien les nettoyer mais
est-ce vraiment suffisant pour se
prémunir contre les effets néfastes des
pesticides nous avons montré
l'équipement de protection de Jean-Marie
au Professeur Alain Garigou de
l'Université de Bordeaux
est-ce que je pose tout de suite c'est
le fait que ce tablier là il va pas
protéger les manches il va pas frotter
protéger la chemise Alain Garigou a
contribué à l'étude peste expo réalisé
en France au début des années 2000 en
grande culture et en viticulture
les chercheurs ont évalué notamment
l'efficacité des équipements de
protection adoptés par les agriculteurs
lorsqu'ils manipulent les pesticides tu
crois que tu pourrais me traduire les le
guide technique et
regarder sur le site internet ou pas
alors j'ai pas encore regardé sur le
site internet
ils ont mesuré leur niveau de
contamination pendant la préparation des
solutions lors de l'application et
pendant le nettoyage des appareils les
conclusions sont stupéfiantes
il y a des gens qui font l'effort de
porter des équipements de protection et
ils ne sont pas protégés autant qu'on
pouvait le penser
pendant la phase de préparation les gens
qui portaient des équipements des
protections étaient légèrement moins
contaminé que ceux qui n'en portaient
pas mais l'écart n’étaient pas si
important que ça quand on s'est
intéressé à la phase de traitement on
s'est rendu compte que les gens qui
portaient des équipements de protection
étaient plus contaminés que ceux qui
n'en portaient pas
comment est-ce possible plus de 90% du
passage des pesticides dans le corps se
fait par voie cutanée et certains
produits conçus pour pénétrer les
cellules végétales ou animales passent à
travers des équipements de protection
même enveloppé de la tête aux pieds les
utilisateurs de pesticides sont à risque
d'abord il suffoque et porte mal les
combinaisons de plus un fort niveau de
transpiration facilite le passage des
pesticides au travers de la combinaison
ce qui va faire la protection du
travailleur exposé à un produit chimique
et aux pesticides c'est la réaction dual
entre le matériau qui constitue la
combinaison et les ingrédients qui
constituent le produit chimique cette
réaction chimique ne sera pas la même si
on change de produit
donc ça veut dire que si j'utilise un
tablier il faut le rincer après usage il
faut nettoyer ses vêtements se doucher
le plus tôt possible pour éviter que les
produits passent par le corps il
faudrait changer de combinaison ou de
matériaux de combinaison chaque fois
qu'on va changer de pesticides ça veut
dire qu'il n'existe pas d'équipements de
protection générique qui porterait de
toutes les pesticides sur une longue
durée ça ça n'existe pas
au fur et à mesure que les scientifiques
documentent la toxicité des pesticides
de nouvelles molécules font leur
apparition par exemple l'utilisation
d'une famille de pesticides les SD hi
s'est accru depuis une dizaine d'années
ces fongicides limitent la prolifération
des champignons et des moisissures en
culture maraîchère en viticulture et en
grandes cultures ils sont largement
utilisés en Europe et en Amérique du
Nord
dans les laboratoires de l'Université
Paris Cité la chercheuse Sylvie Bortoli
et ses collègues se sont intéressés aux
effets potentiels des SDHI sur la santé
humaine alors ce qui nous a perturbés
c'est la découverte que finalement c'est
ces pesticides ont été conçus pour avoir
un mode d'action qui est très
particulier qui est de cibler la
mitochondrie
les mitochondries assurent la survie des
cellules en leur fournissant de
l’énergie or les SDHI bloquent une
enzyme des mitochondries les prises de
leurs principales sources d'énergie et
donc tu les cellules des moisissures
les tests en laboratoire montrent que
les SD hi bloquent aussi une enzyme
identique chez les abeilles les vers de
terre et les humains on sait que lorsque
cet enzyme est inactivé par des des
mutations génétiques chez l'humain et
bien cela
occasionne des des pathologies graves
des neuropathies et également des
cancers des formes rares de cancer
les chercheurs estiment qu'on doit
suspendre l'utilisation des SD hi le
temps d'évaluer leurs dangers potentiel
de manière indépendante d'appliquer le
principe de précaution
Louis Robert celui à qui l'on doit en
quelque sorte la tenue de la commission
parlementaire sur les pesticides au
Québec poussent la réflexion plus loin
encore
moi j'utilise plus l'argument de LA
SCIENCE AGRONOMIQUE qui dit que on peut
faire sans ces produits là Louis Robert
dénonce toujours haut et fort
l'ingérence et l'influence du lobby des
pesticides il est selon lui possible et
rentable d'utiliser les pesticides
uniquement en dernier recours et de
protéger du même coup la santé des
agriculteurs
les techniques
alternatives de contrôle des amis
cultures qui proviennent de la recherche
agronomique ils sont pas valorisés du
tout et ils continuent de s'enfiler
parce qu'il s'en fait il s'en fait c'est
incroyable tout ce qu'on pourrait aller
chercher qu'on pourrait transférer sur
les fermes actuellement qui fera en
sorte qu'on réduit l'usage épaisseur
d'au moins 50% dans très court terme
mais la dépendance aux pesticides en
agriculture est souvent difficile à
surmonter la pression des ravageurs et
des maladies et grandes les producteurs
craignent les baisses de rendement
quand vous êtes dans un système de pluie
longtemps depuis l'enfance quasiment
vous avez repris la ferme de vos parents
vous avez été formaté dans un système
unique de production externe vous avez
fait des investissements et même si vous
en supportez les conséquences dans votre
chair et bien vous avez du mal à
envisager autre chose comme système de
production c'est extrêmement dur de
changer ça
les agriculteurs
sont vraiment laissés à eux-mêmes ils
sont pas avantagés pour fight changement
parce que ça prend de la pluie ça prend
des connaissances des résultats de
recherche des méthodes d'affaires des
méthodes pratiquées dans les champs
au pays le processus d'homologation des
pesticides de l'agence de réglementation
de la lutte antiparasitaire de Santé
Canada larla est aussi de plus en plus
critiquée
des voies célèbres contre la grande
place qu'elle laisse à l'industrie des
pesticides dans l'évaluation de leurs
effets sur la santé humaine la relah
s'appuie majoritairement sur les études
et les données fournies par l'industrie
je pense que l'industrie a montré qu'il
y avait pas la crédibilité pour pour
être un joueur
pertinent puis honnête dans dans le
processus d'homologation
ils sont en trop grands conflits
d'intérêts pour le faire
inviter à réagir à ces critiques l'art
là a refusé notre demande d'entrevue le
processus d'homologation des pesticides
fait actuellement l'objet d'une révision
l'agence dit vouloir accroître
l'utilisation de données réelles et de
conseils indépendants afin de mieux
éclairer les décisions visant à protéger
la santé humaine et l'environnement mais
ces conclusions ne sont pas encore
rendus publics
pourquoi on continue à vouloir dépendre
de compagnie qui cherche à maximiser
leur profit en vendant des produits
dangereux et toxiques qui contaminent
l'environnement et notre santé pour des
dizaines et des dizaines d'années à
venir
l'industrie réplique que les études
qu'elle soumettent à la relat respectent
les normes internationales de bonnes
pratiques de laboratoire et elle affirme
que tout pesticide homologué au Canada
est sans danger si il est utilisé
conformément aux instructions
d'industrie est bien plus fort que
la parole des souris
en attendant les agriculteurs victimes
des pesticides
déploiements efforts pour faire enfin
reconnaître leur maladie et être
indemnisées
[Musique]
en France le combat d'Antoine Lambert
prend maintenant une tournure bien
personnelle il révèle pour la première
fois qu'il doit lui-même lutter contre
la maladie le cancer est-ce que c'est en
lien avec les pesticides c'est une
maladie qui est en tableau
qui pour lequel pour l'instant je
n'arrive pas à me faire reconnaître
puisque je suis un refus
mais
je contesterai le refus quand vous en
êtes à vous battre pour votre propre
six mois plus tard sa maladie est
finalement reconnue
[Musique]
bon courage ouais ben c'est pas facile
tous les jours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un drame comme tant d'autres qui
bouleverse la vie des victimes des
pesticides et de leurs proches